I need a break Kaldur you me Wally we we
founded this team without him I
understand it's time time time for
Robert II Tim where are you going Jonas
Jeff I think we want the same things
saying things really Batman I just
resigned from the Justice League and at
least their leaders were elected
democratically I want nothing to do with
Batman Incorporated the truth is I don't
trust you especially after what you
pulled in there today by any pool I'm
sorry Virgil maybe you can find a new
mentor one who's less damaged please
tell me what all right
[Music]
alright alright everybody is Charlie so
we got to talk about Wally West the
first couple of episodes of Young
Justice why he's coming back in some of
the big WTF moments from those first
three most of you probably noticed they
dropped the first three episodes
back-to-back it'll be like that every
single week we're still doing a giveaway
for that DC streaming service all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite Young Justice
moment on the video uh name a new winner
at the end of this but the big things
first Wally West even though he's still
technically dead they don't know what
happened - they think that he's dead
they've memorialized him as of the
season two finale with that special
statue that Bart is looking at in his
new very Wally West looking costume is
like an amalgam of Bart's previous
costume with the face covering over his
eyes like the special visor in the
yellow from Wally West's costume so he's
the new kid flash for all intents and
purposes so the big thing about Wally
West in the episode is that even though
everyone still believes that he's dead
and Nightwing is using it as his excuse
to take a break
quote-unquote from the team that within
the two-year time jump you find out
exactly why he did that the sort of
builds into the idea of the outsiders
moniker that they're giving this season
of Young Justice Young Justice Outsiders
because it's outside the Justice League
so everybody's fractured you get a
couple nods to McGann leading the Young
Justice team she's officially head of
the team now like you see there Gama
team in the background with Bart in the
Wally West looking costume it's a bit of
the reason why they're being very light
with their wally west easter eggs in the
first couple of episodes there's so many
new characters so many new story arcs so
many other things they have to introduce
this everybody's gonna get their day in
the Sun so they just can't do everything
in the first episode then you see
another wally west reference when
Nightwing goes to recruit Artemis who's
living with Roy's clone and his
with chesh Iyer who's apparently raising
her if you were confused about what's
going on here this is not them as a
couple like Artemis is not with Royce
clone because there are a lot of couples
on the TV show like they kind of let you
know what people's relationships were
especially with McGann and Superboy in
their big moment but she's just living
there obviously still dealing with the
trauma of losing Wally she keeps looking
at his picture and linger on it for a
while she's woken up by Bruce Lee the
dog that she got with Wally West who
then has a really long scene at the end
of the episode as the credits play that
really somber lullaby sounding song that
kind of makes you want to cry because
you're looking at the little Wally West
figure that Bruce Lee is cradling
underneath the table there that's just a
different version of the theme song from
the beginning of the episode this is
what their theme song sounds like now
it's a little more hair-raising a little
more anxiety inducing like things are
getting so much crazier and they kind of
reflect that in some of the big moments
during these episodes like it's a little
more gruesome because it's not on
Cartoon Network anymore so that's why my
WTF moments are way crazier than you
would ever see on network television
especially in a cartoon that you would
think is aimed for children but this is
meant to be a little more adult so
before we talk about that though
why Wally West is coming back like very
clearly they're setting this up for some
big payoff where he eventually does come
back but it's so early in the new
episodes and they've just started
explaining what everybody is doing we
haven't even gotten that many scenes
with Bart Allen in his new sort of Kid
Flash costume so that's why I'm not
expecting to see a whole lot more Wally
West focused scenes at least till the
second half of the season like the first
half of the season is all about
metahuman trafficking so first things
first they learn about this mystery in
the first couple of episodes you meet a
couple of the new characters like geo
force Breanna Markov and halo like the
probably one of the craziest new
characters not dead not dead we'll talk
about her in a second but by the time
they start dealing with more flash
focused things the idea of the Speed
Force I mean the Speed Force technically
doesn't exist in the Young Justice
universe as the creator's explain it a
couple years ago but I think that's just
laying the groundwork for them to
discover what the Speed Force is do the
same way they did in the comics so if
you're not a big flash comic book reader
what happened is is when the flash
debuted for the first time it was
originally Jay Garrick then during the
Silver Age it was Barry Allen then
during the modern age it became Wally
West the main version of the flash what
happened is is that during the Golden
Age in the Silver Age the flash just ran
really fast nobody understood why or
like why his body didn't fly apart
everything we know about the Speed Force
was developed during the 80s the 90s the
modern age of the Wally West Mark Waid
comics so he's the person to introduce
the concept of the Speed Force before
that what they said is is that the older
speedsters like Jay Garrick max mercury
they tapped into something called the
speed field eventually Wally West
becomes the fastest version of the flash
because that's more exciting like you
have a brand-new flash you want him to
be the most badass version ever like
every time you introduce
but he knew he has to be a little bit
better than the guy before so the logic
for explaining why wally west was the
fastest version of the flash ever was is
because he had the most direct
connection to this thing that they
called the speedforce the true source of
their power whereas like the older
flashes jay garrick max mercury had
previously only sort of bumped up
against the idea of the Speed Force
Wally West had a very spiritual direct
connection to that so he could fully tap
into that force and that became the
Speed Force so thence forth all flashes
gain their power from that place so what
happened is is that later because Barry
Allen had died during crisis on Infinite
Earths they learned that both he and
speedsters pretty much any speedster
that died because of the way the Speed
Force changed their bodies when they
would die they would turn into pure
energy in their bodies would return to
the Speed Force so that's how people
like you Bart Thawne reverse-flash kept
coming back even though he seemingly
died and how Barry Allen came back
because he had been trapped in the Speed
Force ever since he had seemingly died
during crisis that's why I think the
Young Justice is doing their own version
of that albeit with Wally West coming
back from the Speed Force and using that
as a way to learn more about the Speed
Force inside this particular animated
universe so because that is a really big
arc in a really big concept in a really
big payoff for Artemis's character like
she's probably gonna be really sad about
this for most of this part of the season
maybe the second part of the season -
they got a deal with a metahuman
trafficking they got a deal with
Darkseid the light all this other stuff
there's just so much going on that I
think that they're gonna save this for
much much later but what they'll do is
they'll probably just start teasing it
like we haven't even gotten scenes with
bart allen using his powers yet but let
me know in the comments do you actually
think that they're doing the same thing
with wally that they did with barry
allen in like flash rebirth and learning
about the Speed Force in this universe
my really big WTF moments from the
episodes just starting with number five
there were a lot but I just did my top
five so Black Lightning killing the
little girl who turned out to be plasmas
that just broke him obviously he wanted
to quit the Justice League then number
four half of the Justice League winds up
quitting including Batman so this is all
built into those Easter eggs like Batman
and the outsiders Young Justice
Outsiders Batman quit the Justice League
in the comic
a long time ago in the spun off a title
called Batman and the outsiders so a lot
of the new characters that you see are
actually from that comic book-like
Metamorpho in katana when Black
Lightning says Batman Incorporated he's
actually talking about an actual Grant
Morrison comic book the plot was very
different from what happened in this
episode it was just Bruce Wayne
revealing that he was the person behind
Batman's tech not revealing that he was
Batman just that he made all of his toys
three the many deaths of Halo so she was
a fun new character we haven't seen a
whole lot of her we'll get a lot more of
her in episodes 4 5 & 6 next week when
they dropped the next batch of episodes
but I love the way that she died several
times in the episode and it would always
be like not dead you see like half of
her face had gotten burned off and then
she just sit up like a I'm good
everybody fine when the second plasmus
the little boy holds his hand over her
face remember this is superheated plasma
and just burns her to death and then she
sits right back up again no worries I'm
fine there's still life in me number
two's the gruesome death of geo force
and his twin brothers parents if this
were a cartoon network you would just
see that happening off screen and they
would see like a foot hanging on to
frame like they wouldn't show you all
this blood the number one is probably
just the idea of what's they're doing
with that Children's Hospital like the
metahuman gene activation process just
wheeling little kids in and basically
drowning them to death to activate their
powers so let me know in the comments
what was your favorite hardcore moment
during the episode and keep in mind this
is just the beginning like they're just
trying to give you an idea for what the
new episodes are gonna feel like
obviously it's gonna get way crazier
towards the back half of the season if
there's any special videos that you guys
want me to make or big questions leave
them in the comments below
congratulations American paese you're
the giveaway winner from my last big DC
video please email me on the about page
my channel so I can get your details
click here to rewatch the opening scene
from Young Justice season 3 episode 1
and click here to learn all about
Avengers endgame and Kevin Feige plans
for x-men and Namor thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]